tchac tchac tchac tchac cas je m'entends
le toc toc toc
tapez pas comme des idiots oui c'est la
mort vivant quelqu'un ment vivent en
quoi ces dames au vivant n'attendons pas
que la mort nous prennent du talent
cecchin khimki qui n'a le droit qui n'a
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors
ça
[Musique]
et là et brooks en titi au divan qui
sent bon
[Applaudissements]
qui est là c'est la diablesse a bien
investi la diablesse les gondoles à
venise
[Musique]
la sorcière la sorcière de la sorcière
de ouarzazate à sortir qui ça resserre
encore j'avais 20 ans je tiendrais c'est
le vent
[Rires]
m
et pendant que les
et là et bien j'étais viré c'est saut à
107 tabac so so so so so cola
[Applaudissements]
moore cichocki chaka chaka
[Rires]
c'est le squelette le squelette qui à ce
que laissent on lui demande
leïla leïla c'est le clown qui fait peur
le clown rouge un peu de bobo à l'asie
va calmer un peu on a dit clown si ces
déchets seront toutes et ottawa
qu'est ce qui vous a écouté du bois
depuis qui a fait plus de musique elle a
pris dans la gueule la mousson dans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]